foreign
[Music]
books today we're pretending we're
pretending that it's December 13 2022
again and the Radeon RX 7900 XT is being
released for the first time but this
time with nine months of driver
development and 150 us slashed off the
MSRP oh and the g-force RTX 4060 series
and rx70 600 series have also been
released but you don't need to worry
about that the point is the 7900 XT
released with driver-related performance
issues that was seen in a few of the
games that we test with and then there's
a 900 us MSRP now the MSRP is still 900
U.S but there's generally at least one
model available for 750 us with multiple
models priced below 800 us and that
being the case we felt a re-review was
in order to see just how much better the
day one 7900 XT reviews could have been
but before we get into it today's
sponsor spot is brought to you by
skytech Gaming and their collaboration
with Intel and Signal RGB to create a
Diablo 4 inspired PC which were given
away to one lucky gamer this
one-of-a-kind Masterpiece features
swirling potions that react with your
health and resources in real time this
is made possible by the signal RGB app
which synchronizes RGB devices from any
brand to bring you a cohesive lighting
experience the hand-painted chest also
contains a 13th gen Intel Core i5 13600k
and GeForce RTX 4070 so to enter the
giveaway click the link in the video
description
okay so this isn't going to be a full
top-down review as not everything has
changed in regards to the Radeon RX 7900
XT so we'll look at the games that have
seen performance improvements a few that
haven't and then the 15 game average and
then from all of that we will
recalculate a cost per Frame data
now on hand for testing I have a couple
of Radeon RX 1700 xt's that I've not
looked at before and some of these
models have been available for 750 USD
over the past few weeks and one such
model is the sapphire pulse which drop
down as low as 720 Midway through July
and has been a hundred dollars below the
MSRP since March of this year and at the
time of making this video it's priced at
seven hundred and seventy dollars US but
I do expect to see that 750 us price or
lower return in the not too distant
future also on hand is the ASRock
Phantom gaming which currently sits at
780 U.S but again did drop as low as 720
us last month and has been priced at 800
or lower since March of this year
then we have the MSI gaming Trail
classic which is a pretty difficult
model to come by and currently it isn't
being sold at Newegg that's not to say
though that neweggs never sold it they
have sold this model in the past for 780
us at least that was the lowest price
that they've sold it for so this MSI
model hasn't hit the rock bottom prices
that we've seen from ASRock and Sapphire
it is also worth noting that MSI was
pretty slow with their 7900 series
releasing their custom models a few
months late so this has likely
influenced the pricing
now for testing we're using our ryzen 7
7800x 3D test system using 32 gigabytes
of ddr5 6000 cl30 memory with the latest
display drivers speaking of display
drivers though the 7900 XT will be
compared with our day one review driver
with the latest driver to see how much
progress AMD has made on the driver
front over the past nine months so let's
get into it
first up we have The Last of Us Part One
and here AMD has made some improvements
boosting performance at 1080p by 14 it's
also great to see a 19 improvement over
the 6950 XT and although that's still
well under what AMD were targeting it is
much better than the four percent
Improvement we saw previously that
margin though is reduced to 11 1440p
taking the average frame rate from 89
FPS with the old driver to 99 FPS with
the new driver so it's still a nice game
but it's not quite as impressive as what
we saw at 1080p
then at 4K we're only seeing an 8 uplift
for the newer driver but with the 4070
TI falling away at this higher
resolution that does hand the 7900 XT a
rather large 21 performance advantage
okay moving on to Resident Evil 4 and
here we're seeing no performance
improvement with the latest driver and I
have to say this is pretty typical from
our 15 game sample even as we increase
the resolution there is no performance
Improvement resulting in the same 155
FPS at 1440p and 92 FPS at 4K and again
this sort of result is fairly typical
When comparing the release driver with
the latest driver in a wide range of
games
now the only other game besides The Last
of Us Part One to show big performance
gains with the new driver or really any
performance Improvement is Forza Horizon
5. here the latest driver improved the
1700 xt's performance by 19 at 1080p
allowing it to just Edge out the 4072i
by a mere 5 margin still that's a great
Improvement given what we saw previously
and well previously it was slow in the
6950 XT so certainly a nice performance
injection there for arduino3
sadly though the margin is greatly
reduced at 1440p and now the latest
driver is only offering a 12 boost which
admittedly that's still a nice uplift
but it's also quite a bit less when
compared to what we saw at 1080p
finally at 4K we're only looking at a
four percent performance boost but that
was enough to basically match the 6950
XT so
not an amazing result at this extreme
resolution but a much needed Improvement
all the same
okay so the f122 Benchmark that only saw
a very minor performance improvements at
1080p basically within the margin of
error we're seeing just a two percent
increase for the average frame rate then
at 1440p we're looking at less than a
two percent increase going from 118 fps
to 120 FPS and then out to a three
percent increase at 4K though it is
worth mentioning that the one percent
lows saw a more notable seven percent
increase and this was fairly consistent
throughout the f122 testing
now here's a look at the 15 game average
data starting with the 1080p numbers so
as I said just two games saw big
performance gains with nothing much
happening for the other 13 games and as
a result overall performance was boosted
by just three percent at 1080p that will
certainly help the 1700 XT but in terms
of overall performance it's hardly a
game changer then at 1440p the margin is
reduced to just three percent taking the
overall frame rate from 135 fps to 139
FPS so while it is nice to see any kind
of performance Improvement it's not
exactly that meaningful for the 1700
xt's overall performance
and then finally at 4K we're also only
looking at a three percent boost overall
so nothing to write home about and
therefore I think it's best that we just
move on to the cost per frame analysis
and we'll start with the cost per Frame
data based on the manufacturer's
suggested retail pricing figures at the
still official MSRP of 900 us the 7900
XT is a complete joke offering the same
cost per frame as previous generation
parts that were also poor value upon
release such as the 330 us RX 6600. in
my opinion you'd ideally want a part
such as the 1700 XT offering at least 15
percent better value than the RX 6800
but at the 900 MSRP it actually ended up
being seven percent more expensive
AMD released the 7900 XT at 750 us it
would have been 13 cheaper than the RX
6800 and that's significantly closer to
where I think it should be basically as
I alluded to in my previous content this
product really should have cost 700 us
but 750 is certainly a massive
improvement from nine hundred dollars of
course the problem all current
generation gpus face is a massive
surplus of previous generation gpus even
today the 6950 XT can still be had for
as little as 640 us which makes a
900.7900
XT utterly useless but at 750 us if
you're in the market for a high-end GPU
you'd surely pay the small premium for
the 7900 XT it's very likely going to
age better with future driver
development and it has a little bit more
vram for good measure
it also beats out the 4070 TI which
costs 800 us there is just no way frame
generation is worth paying a 16 premium
for most Gamers and of course if you
happen to play competitive multiplayer
titles then frame generation is
completely worthless and in my opinion
surely that 20 gigabyte vrm buffer
offered by the 7900 XT is a
significantly greater draw card given
the 4072i only has 12 gigabytes but of
course let me know what you think about
that in the comments section below
and then finally I'll just quickly touch
on power usage not that anything's
really changed here and we are looking
at total system figures when compared to
the 4070 TI total system usage in Hitman
3 was increased by nine percent and both
gpus did produce the same frame rate in
this game so the 4072i it's certainly
more efficient but as we see in this
example there's not always a lot in it
that said when looking at Spider-Man
remastered we see the 7900 XT did push
total system usage 25 higher though it
was seven percent faster so again the
GeForce GPU it's certainly more
efficient but the difference isn't
always going to be that significant
so there you have it what could have
been for our day 17900 XT review and
speaking of which I did conclude my
review nine months ago by saying this
GPU needed to cost no more than 750 U.S
that was the absolute highest price I
could see a 7900 XT making sense and
nine months later that appears to be as
true as ever and thankfully now it is
possible to purchase a 7900 XT at that
price well I suppose depending on the
pricing in your region but when I was
starting to piece this video together a
week or so before its release the
sapphire pulse version was available at
750 us over at newegg.com though it is
back up to 770 as of the 1st of August
the power color hellhound is also often
available at 750 and at the time of
making this video it currently is though
most other models are up around 770 to
790 dollars
so the 1700 XT it isn't always available
at 750 us and without an official price
cut pricing will continue to be all over
the place but you should absolutely be
on the lookout for deals as they do
regularly pop up
now as nice as the massively improved
performance and Forza Horizon 5 and The
Last of Us Part One is overall the 7900
XT isn't much faster today than it was
nine months ago when we tested it for
the first time so while the improved
performance in a few select tiles are
certainly very nice it's not a massive
Factor here in fact the biggest factor
is the heavily discounted price from 900
to 750 and again while this doesn't
apply to all models in probably all
regions any 7900 XT that's priced much
over 750 U.S should be ignored and when
compared to the GeForce competition the
absolute cheapest GeForce RTX 470 TI on
NewEgg right now costs 800 and you'd be
mad to buy that over a discounted 7900
XT in my opinion
all said and done it's a huge shame that
AMD has stuffed up the 7900 XT release
as badly as they have two of myself
recently talked at length about how
poorly the Radeon division has been
executing for years now and although
rdna3 fell shorter performance targets
at the right price it could have still
been a huge success
that said I think this generation was
destined to fail anyway and ultimately
it failed because the cryptocurrency
boom ended overnight leaving AMD and
Nvidia with massive silicon orders from
tsmc and Samsung and that of course led
to a massive surplus of previous
generation gpus that Gamers didn't
really want at least not without a hefty
discount applied but alternatively had
the cryptocurrency boom not ended when
it did this generation would have been
even worse so like I said it was
destined to fail either way
so while I believe AMD should have
released the 7900 XT at 750 us from the
get-go or even lower than that
potentially that would have left them
holding a massive bag of 6900 XT and
6950 XTS a situation they absolutely
didn't want to find themselves in
but even so you have to wonder if making
that sacrifice would have been worth it
to claw back some market share from
Nvidia I certainly think that would have
been the winning long-term strategy it's
really hard to say without some sort of
crystal ball that can provide us with an
alternate timeline where they did what I
think they should have done but really
there's a few things you can take away
from here firstly the 7900 XT it was
discounted so shortly after release that
I'm not sure how much difference it
would have made to 6900 series sales
anyway they probably could have started
at 750 us received much better reviews
like glowing reviews compared to what
they did receive and still cleared out
the older Arduino 2 stock and what we
really do know is that this is yet
another generation that's passed us by
where the Radeon group continues to
tread through the waters of a relevancy
and that is unfortunate for gamers
everywhere
and on that bombshell I am going to end
this video hopefully you guys appreciate
it uh sort of re-review of the 1700 XT
much better product at 750 us and of
course with those sort of driver related
issues pretty well sorted out yeah just
in general much better product
anyway as I said that is gonna that's
gonna end this one if you'd like to
support the channel more directly and
get some cool perks in return we do have
float plane or patreon signing up to
either one of those will give you access
to our exclusive Discord server for
members only monthly live stream uh q a
stuff and behind the scenes content so
check that out if you're interested but
if not that is perfectly fine and I
would like to thank you for watching
this video I'm your host Steve see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign